okay, now now that we know now that we
know how the Phi function works and
how that we have to integrate the five
function to
calculate the probability for the
randomized random variable. Let's go ahead and apply this idea to
The exercise so go back here.
now
instead of using word from
alpha each time you want to calculate?
five function
the normal distribution is the normal distribution
is
I don't want to use the port standard.
But it's it's it's probability. These are our Universal.
So rather than calculating it by hand
or
programmatically just look up the table. So for example
if I opened up the z-score.
If I open up the the table for this course.
It will tell you that for example if you want to know.
five function the value five function
for the value set of negative 1
it's 1.5866. And that's where we
calculate it, right?
and if it's not precisely one, but it's like
1.01 1.021.03 then
you can look up the row to find.
You know.
That probably for that particular.
You know value.
so
we will use this table.
to calculate
the CDF of
our you know problem.